hey guys we're going to talk about how
to lower uric acid uric acid basically
is a byproduct to proteins and it can
leak into the joints and create a lot of
like arthritic type pain especially in
the gout the big toe and the lower part
of the feet and also turn into kidney
stone so it can be very very painful so
what causes that mainly is high-fructose
corn syrup and that's a lot of soft
drinks a lot of the junk foods out there
you probably know people who consume
that but I know you don't consume that
too much sugar will do that kidney
problems fasting can actually increase
your uric acid in your body ketosis can
do it as well
and diuretics okay an excessive
consumption of meat so these are things
you just want to look at but here's the
remedy it's potassium citrate if you
took potassium citrate you could knock
out uric acid pretty fast it helps
neutralize that and so you want to start
cleaning up this this stuff right here
of course don't get off the ketosis
don't stop fasting you clean this up
start adding potassium but you could
also get it from a lot of vegetables and
that's why when I recommend ketosis you
know you're switching from running on
glucose to running on fats okay when you
do that you're changing your whole fuel
system and I recommend adding a lot of
vegetables to that because your body you
use pH is going to start becoming acidic
you're going to get rid of a lot of your
gas food crystals and so you want to
have a lot of vegetables to flush all
that out of there if you do a ketosis
diet without vegetables you're going to
end up with probably gout and kidney
stones so you want to consume that so
anyway I want to bring up that point and
go ahead and start doing that and thank
you so much for watching
hey guys thank you so much for watching
please click the subscribe button and I
will see you in the next video